هذا واتهم المتحدث باسم قوات الدفاع
الاوكرانيه الجنوبيه روسيا بتعمد استهداف
البنيه التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه لاخراج
اوكرانيا من اسواق الحبوب العالميه
مهاجمه البنيه التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه
في منطقه اوديسا ليله الماضيه يستمر العدو
بممارسه ارهابه والاعيب الجوع وفعل كل ما
يمكن لاخراج اوكرانيا من اسواق الحبوب
العالميه
في هذه الاثناء نشرت قوات الدفاع الجنوبيه
الاوكرانيه صورا قالت انها لاثار هجوم
الطائره المسيره الروسيه اعلى البنيه
التحتيه لموانئ اوتيسا
من جهته اكد النائب في البرلمان
الاوكرانيه
حاويه غادرت صباح اليوم ميناء اوديس المطل
على البحر الاسود واضاف ان سفينه الحاويات
التي ظلت في ميناء اوديسا منذ يوم الثاني
والعشرين من فبراير من العام الماضي غادرت
الان واعلنت اوكرانيا الاسبوع الماضي فتح
ممر انساني في البحر الاسود للسماح بابحار
سفن الشحن العالقه في موانئها منذ بدء حرب
الروسيه او الحرب الروسيه عليها
اظهرت بيانات ملاحيه تحرك سفينه الحاويات
الاوكراني في وقت مبكر من صباح اليوم بحسب
البيانات فان من المتوقع ان تصل السفينه
الى ميناء امبرليه التركي المطل على بحر
مرمره بمدينه اسطنبول في الثامن عشر من
هذا الشهر وقالت وزاره البنيه التحتيه في
اوكرانيا في بيان ان الممر المؤقت الذي تم
انشاؤه للسفن المدنيه من والى موانئ البحر
الاسود سيستخدم بشكل اساسي لاجلاء السفن
التي كانت في
مواليدسادين
ومن تشيرنو مورسكا
معنى الجزيره عامر لافي ومن دونيتسك مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين الدغير لرسم تطورات
الساعه الاخيره ونبدا معك على الرفي
نعم ازدهار في اطار حرب البحر الاسود وحرب
الحبوب يعني اخبار وتطورات متسارعه حقيقه
في اوديسا وما حولها تبدا بالقصف الذي
طالع ميناء رينيه على نهر الدانوب صباح
هذا اليوم او فجر هذا اليوم وفقا لقياده
القوات الجويه تمكنت من اسقاط ثلاثه عشره
مسيره لكن هذا ليس كل عدد المسيرات التي
تستهدفت البناء وبالتالي سقطت عده مسيرات
او وصلت الى اهدافها في هذا الميناء وفقا
للاداره العسكريه هنا في اوديسا اشتعلت
الكثير من الحرائق داخل البناء وخصوصا في
مستودعات الحبوب في هذا الميناء لكن اكدت
الاداره بانه تمكنت قوات الدفاع المدني من
اطفاء هذه الحرائق بسرعه كبيره اذا هذا
الميناء ريناي يستهدف للمره الثانيه منذ
خروج روسيا من اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب الموانئ
النهريه اسماعيل وريني هي الموانئ التي
عليها وبدات اوكرانيا بالاعتماد عليها
بشكل كبير في محاوله لتصدير منتجاتها من
الحبوب وتمكنت خلال الفتره الماضيه من
تصدير 20% تقريبا من حبوبها عبر هذه
الموانئ التي تمر عبر نهر الدانوب نحو
رومانيا ومنها عبر البحر الاسود بسفن
كبيره الى بقيه اجزاء او دول العالم اذا
روسيا تحاول اغلاق كل الطرق وكل المنافذ
على روسيا على اوكرانيا لمنعها من تصدير
الحبوب وتعلمون طبعا ان الموانئ البحريه
هي مغلقه
وتستهدف بشكل مستمر اول امس كان هناك
استهداف لميناء اوديسا لكن يبقى ان اللافت
اليوم واللافت جدا هو ان سفينه قد تحركت
بالفعل من ميناء اوديسا البحري متجهه نحو
مضيق البسفور وهذه اول سفينه تخرج من
الموانئ البحريه منذ خروج روسيا من
اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب اي السابع عشر من
الشهر الماضي هذه السفينه تخرج في اطار
مكانه اوكر قد اعلنته في العاشر من اغسطس
الماضي عن فتحها لممرات انسانيه او وصفتها
بالانسانيه لاخراج السفن العالقه منذ
بدايه الحرب هنا في اوكرانيا اي في اشباط
ونوضح هنا بان العديد من السفن كان لم
تتمكن المغادره من خلال اتفاقيه نقل
الحبوب لانها لم تكن تحمل حبوب البضائع
اخرى وبالتالي لم تشملها الاتفاقيه وهي
محتجزه منذ اكثر من عام ونصف هذه الخطوه
الاوكرانيه تريد ان تخرج هذه السفن اذا
هذه السفينه خرجت بضمانات اوكرانيه
بحمايتها في المياه الاقليميه الاوكرانيه
لكن بعد ذلك يبقى السؤال الكبير كيف تظهر
كيف ستتصرف روسيا مع هذه السفينه هل
ستحاول ايقافها في عرض البحر خطوه مهمه
ولافته كان الجميع يتوقع بان لا تنجح هذه
الخطوه الاوكرانيه على اعتبار انه لن يجرؤ
ولن تجرا اي سفينه روسيا اوكرانيه غير
اوكرانيا من الموجوده هنا في موانئ
اوكرانيا على الخروج في من هذه الموانئ
النقطه المهمه الاخرى ايضا في اخبار
المتسارعه لهذا اليوم هو ما اعلنته قياده
اداره امن الدوله الاوكرانيه التي اعترفت
صراحه بانها هي ومن خلال مسيرات مائيه
صنعتها بايديها صناعه محليه هي التي
استهدفت السفن الروسيه في البحر الاسود
وسفينه ناقله النفط ايضا في البحر الاسود
وعرضت صورا لهذه المسيرات التي صنعت في
اوكرانيا